the nevada department of employment says  people filing for  certain unemployment benefits should  expect a delay in payments  deters says it is waiting for direction  from the department of labor  on how it should reimplement pandemic  emergency unemployment compensation  and state extended benefits now both of  those programs  lapsed before the coveted relief bill  was signed into law on sunday by  president trump  those two programs offer extended  benefits to claimants  who have exhausted their regular  unemployment benefits this delay will  also impact people filing a new pandemic  unemployment assistance claim